so i'm gonna date myself today and and
you're gonna laugh at me but maybe we're
gonna laugh at this together
so i'm listening to a song earlier and
i'm telling mario i'm like man i love
this song
it's just a new song that came out it's
great he says what song is it
i said it starts it goes like this he
says hey baby
what's your name uh let me talk to you
let me buy you a drink
i'm t payne he says pat this is not a
new song i said what are you talking
about
he said this is a song that came out in
o4
i said dude that's impossible they said
i'm telling you it's a
17 year old song i said come on mario
says i'm telling you it's a 17 year old
song
so i go online and i search and then yep
if he's right it's a
17 year old song came out and i think
all 405
and he says you've never heard this race
i've never heard this before
then we sat down and he says have never
never heard this before i said well you
got to realize
2004 i made a big decision in 04
i cut out partying i cut out radio
i cut out drinking if i do have a drink
today
it's one maybe a month and it's simply
because i'm out with a few people
i said i replaced everything with
working on myself
developing myself reading books i didn't
watch any of these ridiculous shows
and change life so i don't know what
radio is i haven't listened to radios
and so
forth literally
my cars they've never had the radio on
the
only reason radio's ever been on in my
car is because somebody drove my car
you will never see radio being on
in my car you're just not gonna get that
to happen with me right
so what does this have to do with you
well went to the bank the other day and
we're talking about this
i'm at the bank and and uh i go in and i
stand on the side and the guy says sir
our tellers can help you i said i'm
telling you i think you can only help me
what i'm
says sir our tellers can help you i said
ron
i'm telling you this is only you he says
sir can you just go talk to the tellers
so i go talk to the tellers and then i
tell the tellers what i'm doing let's
say
15 million or whatever anyways i'm doing
something with them and the teller's
like sir i can't do anything i said can
you please tell your boss over here
he says ron i can't he says what it
calls him says
sure i am so sorry i just thought it was
i said that's iran why would i tell you
like you have to help me
oh my gosh what came next in all the
bankers oh we'd like to get you on
promise i'm a goldman sachs i'm unhappy
i'm happy you know
i'm happy where my money's at and who
manages it i'm good to go
oh but but it's okay but you know you
don't have to have all of it even if
it's just five or ten million of it and
it's not a big deal i said no no i'm
good i'm good where i'm at
anyways then yesterday i'm here in
florida
and i you know the two cards i sold the
gretzky cards i sold for a couple
million dollars i go in to make a
deposit
and i said just here to make a couple
deposits and
the lady says yeah i can show you how to
do it with your phone you don't even
need to come here i said oh really i'm
telling you
my wife's like no we've tried this you
can't he says no i'll show you and i
give the check to the
one the guys and he says uh no ma'am we
he's right you know this is a check that
you have to do and then this
what is this i said just a hockey card i
sold four couple million dollars yeah
you're kidding me no what's the moral of
the story
listen 15 years ago nobody at the bank
would stop me or do anything
people wouldn't come out saying hey you
know can we please manage your
finances and all this other stuff
t-pain buy you a drink
hey baby what's your name let me talk to
you let me buy you a drink empty pain
how the hell did this happen it's called
17 years of being focused and cut not
the fat
and when i tell you with the one quote
by bill gates where he says
you know people overestimate what can
happen short term
and underestimate what can happen in 10
years that's such a factual statement
because if you
only knew the stuff i'm working on right
now if i were to tell you about it it
wouldn't be believable you'd be like hey
you know some of this stuff cannot be
real but that's the life
because certain things were dropped
we're talking about a show earlier
that's
you know guys telling me it's a great
show you gotta watch it
it's on season six thirteen episodes
like season six how many uh how long is
each it's only an hour i said
six times thirteen seventy eight i am
not watching a 78 hour movie
i there's no way i'm gonna watch a 78
hour movie
pat what are you talking about people do
it all the time people can do whatever
the hell they want to do i'm not
watching a 78 hour movie
what value am i getting at it's purely
entertaining i'm not doing it
78 out there used to be a movie back in
the days called north and south
i think it was three episodes two hours
a piece if you watched it it was like
marathon you know
i watched the uh uh leonardo dicaprio
uh what is the one with the arms like
this uh what is that you know what i'm
talking about
oh come on man uh
i cannot believe i don't remember the
name anyways you know which movie it's
three hours right with
and you know he's uh singing and he ends
up dying he saves the girl's life etc
etc
i don't need to watch that 15 i got the
point right
you're gonna need to cut some fat if you
want life to change
but i'm gonna tell you a couple things
here if you
do cut the fat and you do
make certain sacrifices don't be
surprised if your life changes in ways
where your friends family people around
you are going to say things like
well we always knew you were going to
make it you know well you know
they're not going to know what things
you have to do behind closed doors but
you're going to have to cut the fat
and as good as you think it's going to
feel when your life changes i guarantee
you
million times better than what you think
is going to happen when you make those
changes anyways
that's what i was thinking about today
wanted to share this with you
and if there's a video i want you to
watch
if you've not watched it i'm gonna over
recommend this video
because there's that much value in it
it's an interview i did with chip wilson
who is the former founder
of uh uh he is the founder
of lululemon he's a four or five billion
dollar guy if you've never watched it so
much
depth in that interview of you know if
you've not watched it click over here to
watch it having said that
have a wonderful wonderful week
everybody take care bye